[Musique]
le président du département a réuni les
élus en commission permanente ce
mercredi 22 avril de nouveaux
dispositifs de soutien aux filières
horticoles et et qui n'ont été votés
avant de passer à l'examen des dossiers
une motion relative au soutien aux
acteurs de l'accompagnement alimentaire
a été présentée et adoptée à l'unanimité
par l'assemblée délibérante
ce matin la commission permanente se
renier nous avons adopté une motion
extrêmement importante il s'agit de
renforcer l'accompagnement des
associations qui font de l'aide
alimentaire
ici à la réunion nous demandons à ce que
la réunion soit considérée comme telle
priorité à territoires prioritaires en
matière d'accompagnement l'aide
alimentaire pour que la croix rouge
française
la banque alimentaire des mascareignes
puissent voir leur stock être
réalimentés sur le plan national et donc
cette motion était adoptée à l'unanimité
renforcement de l'accompagnement
alimentaire des personnes en difficulté
par ailleurs nous avons adopté aussi des
aides wade fils et agricoles qui sont là
aussi en difficulté
je pense à la filière équine vous savez
tous ceux qui ont développé des
activités autour du cheval bien
aujourd'hui sont en grande difficulté
parce qu'il n'y a plus d'activité de
même que la filière horticole celle qui
produit toutes ces fleurs tous et toutes
ces ces plantes qu'on peut retrouver
dans les jardins de la réunion et bien
la filière équine comme la filière
horticole sont accompagnés par le
département nous avons voté une
enveloppe globale de 200 mille euros
pour la filière horticole et 200000
euros pour la filière équine cela
doivent leur permettre de passer le cap
de cette crise là dans l'immédiat mais
bien sûr des solutions à plus long terme
pourraient être recherchés en lien avec
les producteurs locaux
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
et sociale la collectivité
départementale a su être réactive en
mettant en place le pacte de solidarité
d'urgence sociale à ce jour près de 13
millions d'euros ont été engagés
nous avons débloqué des aides pour tout
ce qui touche à l'accompagnement des
publics en difficulté nous avons mis en
place dans le domaine agricole bien les
paniers de fruits et légumes pays qui
fonctionne bien peu de 15000 chaque
semaine sont distribués à le public
fragile nous avons aussi mis en place un
comité d'action en lien avec l'êta la rs
la caf pour justement bien accompagner
les personnes les plus démunies et donc
je pense à une révision du fsl le fonds
de solidarité logement que nous sommes
en train d'engager une révision de du
fonctionnement de ce dispositif pour ce
sont des des pistes de travail et des
actions qui portent leurs fruits puisque
aujourd'hui je le ressens bien les
réunionnais le savent le département à
travers cette crise mais au delà même de
cette crise le département reste
toujours au plus près des réunionnais
[Musique]